here now former detroit police
commissioner and aspiring michigan
governor uh james craig he's a
gubernatorial candidate chief are you
surprised how bad is it in your mind
you know brian thanks for having me on
the show i got to tell you i'm not
surprised at all
this is expected and you know the
problem with what's going on across our
country today
these lawmakers who stand quiet
when these progressive judges these
progressive da's do what they release
these violent predatory suspects back
into our community they say nothing they
don't speak on behalf of the
vulnerable members of our community but
now that they're victims let's see what
they're going to do now look at lori
lightfoot
she gets out and she says well
we think in response to smash and grabs
but you know the retailers need to hire
more security
where is the outcry
for that teenager that was shot and
right after that the mother who went to
the location where
he was shot
she was shot
and we got two victims the unnecessary
where's the outcry and the outpouring
for that we got progressive judges
progressive da's who are doing nothing
chief uh a couple of things
merrick garland's put 1.6 billion into
criminal justice and fighting crime he's
going to hire another thousand cops
so what's that gonna do we can't get
cops to fill the academies now is this
about money
no this is about politics
these are individuals who are political
servants not public servants look we
know how important police officers are
but when they've been demonized
demoralized not supported you back offer
to defund these so-called moderates so
now moving away from
you know defunding the police to
you know what you you heard the san
francisco mayor all of a sudden
she's now pro hiring police
the problem is how are you going to
support the men and women who do the job
how are we going to encourage young
people to join the forces
it's it's it's it's a look we're coming
into 2022 midterms and they're trying to
clean up their act because they are
failing i'm giving them a big fat f they
are failing these are political chief
servants not public servants because the
guy worked in urban communities about 45
seconds republicans don't make a stand
they don't put up candidates they don't
put a machine behind them to get the
word out what is your message to
republicans while we watch these cities
just disintegrate
my message is simple we need to stand in
unison get behind a candidate that can
take out these progressive
so-called
political leaders out they need to go
and and americans want better i talk all
over the state of michigan right and
they want something different and we're
going to give it to them it's not black
or white it's not right or left it's
right and wrong chief best of luck in
your run look forward to seeing seeing
you rise in the polls
hey thank you so much brian merry
christmas to you and your family
absolutely uh thanks so much we always
love having you on hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else